Oleksandra Matviichuk
Welcome to the program.
Thank you for invitation.
Can I just start by asking you
about today?
You're in Ukraine.
You have seen another wave of missiles
and drones attacking
civilian structures, ends up region
and in the key region.
What can you tell us about this
and what does it mean in the broader
human rights picture
when you speak about the general
human cell?
It's me in that belief in total.
Unfortunately, we can't know
whether the next air alarm started
or when Internet will disappear.
And when we speak about our professional
point of view,
it's the next war crimes
which was committed by Russians,
which we have to document.
And how are you getting on
with documenting?
Because you've been doing it
in real time,
along with other organizations inside
and outside Ukraine.
How is the documentation going?
A large scale invasion started.
We united other efforts with dozens
of regional organizations, and we built
whole Ukrainian network
of local document takers.
And that's why we are able to send
local commentators for the place of crime
when something happened
and they made their own photos
and videos,
speak with people,
collect testimonies, etc..
And the government, your government today
said that these latest attacks
are deliberate attacks against civilians.
So that is a war crime, obviously.
And I wonder
how you get your documenting teams
to the places that are under attack.
It's depends whether the crime
was committed
because Russian troops deliberately
shelling
residential buildings,
schools, churches, hospitals, attack
evacuation corridors, management,
Russian camp systems,
organize forcible deportations
and commit murder,
tortures, rapes, abductions
in the occupied territories.
So when we speak about controlled part
or by Ukrainian government,
which is far from the battle zone,
it's easier
for us to send people
to work on the ground.
But when we speak about the limitation
on the occupied territories,
it's a very difficult job
because these people
who collect information
there can be subjected
to illegal detention and torture.
And also, Alexandra, I've heard that,
you know, even those committing
the crimes
are much less
the victims in the occupied regions.
Maybe many of them are dead by now.
Do you consider that a problem
in terms of accountability in the future?
It's a huge problem
that I am as a Ukrainian human
rights defender,
who have been applying
the law
for many years
to protect people and human dignity
for current moment, have no legal tools
how to protect people
in the occupied territories.
And people there live in a gray zone.
They have no chance
to protect their rights,
their freedom,
their property, their lives,
and they the loved ones.
This means that occupation
is not alternative to the war is just
another form of this war.
You know, we've
we've heard the most terrible stories
about children.
The attack on children,
the forcible deportation of children,
the kidnap of children,
the indoctrination of children,
the forced adoptions of children
over in Russia
and as you know,
the ICC has issued a warrant
for the arrest of Vladimir Putin
and his so-called
commissioner for Children's Affairs.
And her name is Maria Elena Vova Belova.
Do you see this as a good first step?
How do you react
to the ICC arrest warrant?
I welcome this arrest warrant
because it's historical decision.
It's first in the history
of an international criminal court
issued arrest warrant from the current
head of the state,
which is the member of Security Council
of UN
and the State
which has a huge nuclear potential.
This means that
International Criminal Court
emphasize violence against that.
We have to live in the world
the rule of law dictate rules,
not brutal force.
So I want to play a soundbite of.
It was last month
when this woman, Maria,
live over
Bolivia, was talking to Vladimir
Putin in the Kremlin about this
abduction, although she didn't
call it that.
And it was about her adopting a child
from Mariupol. Listen to this.
Did you adopt a child
from Mariupol yourself?
Yes. Thanks. To you.
15 years old.
Now I know what it means to be
a mother of a child from numbers.
It's difficult,
but we definitely love each other.
What do you feel?
I just want to know your feeling
when you first saw that.
No, it's very sensitive topic for me.
And for Ukrainians because it's children
and this is Ukrainian children
who are forcibly reeducated as Russians.
And in the press
release, International Criminal Court
qualified.
This action is a war crime.
But I do believe
that we have to prove that
it's much more bigger.
It's a component of genocide, a policy
which Russia imposed against Ukraine
Okay.
That's a really huge crime,
as you know, is
the highest crime
under international law, genocide.
Tell me what legal route
do you see
from those abductions to actual genocide?
Why do you call it that?
When we
when we stayed there,
this war has genocidal character.
We know just rely upon
the statement of Putin.
And he's surrounding
the Ukraine has no right to exist.
There is no Ukrainian nation.
There is no Ukrainian culture.
There is no Ukrainian language.
But also on actual activities
which restaurants committed in Ukraine.
It's very visible
in occupied territories,
how they forcibly change
identity of people.
They prohibit Ukrainian language.
They try to to persecute,
not try but prosecute
people who express Ukrainian identity.
And in this regard, when we speak
that Ukrainian children are forcibly
reeducated as Russians,
it's a component of this policy
because when we
have this genocidal intent
to destroy it completely
or partially some ethnic group,
there is no obligation
just to kill all members of this group.
You cannot just forcibly change
the identity of members of the group
and the whole group will disappear.
Alexandra,
I want to ask you a personal question.
As a woman, as a human rights activist
trying to pursue now
the most intense cases of your life
in your career,
I assume women are hugely implicated
and are victims
as well as children in this war,
and that's been foisted on your country.
What are your personal reflections
and feelings at this moment in this war?
I have two main feelings.
First, I must be very honest
that I am work in human rights fields.
For 20 years,
since nine of them,
I have been documenting war crimes.
I personally interviewed
hundreds of people
who survived Russian captivity,
and they told me
horrible stories called
they were beaten, raped,
held their fingers scarred.
How they were tortured was electric
and other kinds of horrible details.
But even I,
with all my experience on the ground,
wasn't prepared
for such a level of atrocity
because Russia uses war crimes,
the methods of warfare,
and Russia
attempts to break people
resistance and occupy Ukraine
by inflicting
immense pain on millions of people.
But second,
my feelings it's a feeling of love,
because when large
scale invasion started,
it's resulted in
a huge wave of solidarity
among people in Ukraine.
And we become witness how ordinary
people started
to do extraordinary things.
And when international organizations
evacuated, their personal,
ordinary people remained
and start to do their work.
They broke encirclement
to provide humanitarian aid
they helped people to survive
under artillery fire.
They rescued people who were trapped
into the rubble of residential buildings.
Etc., etc..
And now I think that we,
like never before
have this very sharp telling.
What does it mean to be a human being?
Amazing.
Oleksandra Matviichuk,
thank you so much indeed for joining us.
Thank you.